one coil down 95 to
go welcome to the international science
and engineering fair I'm going to
Atlanta yes if you win Isa it's like
winning the Nobel Prize as a
kid I'm literally going to pass out even
if I don't win it's going to be worth it
this research is really good if we wi
partying is it about the science or the
partying both both my Project's goal was
to solve plastic pollution to work a
safer and cheaper fuel for Zimbabwe to
slow world hunger no pressure the level
of Excellence is so impressive the
stakes are high I feel like I need to
puke that reminds me I need to bring the
Tums I'm weird they're weird we're all
weird together we're going to change the
world the winner
[Applause]
is
[Music]